JOINED NOW BY CNN ROYAL
COMMENTATOR EMILY NASH WHO JUST
ATTENDED THE QUEEN'S STATE
FUNERAL ALONG WITH RICHARD AND
CHRISTIANE WITH ME.
EMILY, WE WATCHED, WE COULD
HEAR.
YOU WERE INSIDE THOSE DOORS.
WHAT DID YOU SEE?
>> IT WAS QUITE AN EXTRAORDINARY
EXPERIENCE FOR ME.
IN 20 YEARS AS A JOURNALIST I
DON'T THINK I'VE EVER FELT
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
WORLD LEADERS, FOREIGN ROYALS
AND DIGNITARIES FROM THIS
COUNTRY AND ACROSS THE GLOBE
GATHERED AND ALSO WITH ORDINARY
PEOPLE WHO ARE PRESENT BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN HONORED BY THE
QUEEN OVER THE LAST YEAR OF HER
LIFE, AND I THINK WHAT WAS
AMAZING ABOUT IT IS THAT
EVERYONE WAS UNIFIED AND CAME
TOGETHER AND FELL SILENT FOR
HER.
THERE WAS ABSOLUTE SILENCE WHEN
THE LAST POST WAS SOUNDED BOTH
INSIDE AND OUT AND THAT'S REALLY
EXTRAORDINARY IN A CONGREGATION
OF 2,000 PEOPLE.
JUST EVERY MOMENT OF IT WAS
EXCEPTIONALLY SPECIAL.
>> WHAT WAS IT LIKE?
I KNOW IT'S GOT TO BE HARD TO
DESCRIBE, BUT TO BE IN
WESTMINSTER ABBEY WITH MORE THAN
2,000 PEOPLE AND THEN TO HAVE
UTTER SILENCE DESCEND?
>> IT WAS, YOU KNOW,
SPINE-TINGLING IS THE WORD I
WOULD USE AND THE MOMENT THE
COFFIN WAS BROUGHT IN, WE HAD
THIS EXTRAORDINARY MUSIC AND THE
SENTENCES FROM THE CHOIR SOARING
THROUGH THE ABBEY, AND I JUST
FELT COMPLETE GOOSEBUMPS, YOU
KNOW?
SEEING THE COFFIN BROUGHT TO THE
FRONT ON THE CATAFALQUE ON THE
PLACE WHERE THE QUEEN WAS
CROWNED AND WHERE SHE WAS
MARRIED JUST WAS -- IT WILL TAKE
ME A LITTLE WHILE TO PROCESS MY
THOUGHTS ABOUT THIS ALL, BUT IT
WAS A HUGE PRIVILEGE TO HAVE
BEEN PRESENT.
>> YOU KNOW, CHRISTIANE, RICHARD
AND I WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
ARCHBISHOP'S COMMENTS,
ARCHBISHOP WELBY ABOUT THE QUEEN
THAT HE CAPTURED, HE DESCRIBED
HER AS JOYFUL AND PRESENT FOR SO
MANY, AND IT SEEMS THAT THAT'S
WHAT YOU FELT.
OBVIOUSLY, WAS THERE THE
DIGNITARIES AND THE PRINCES AND
PRINCESSES FROM SO MANY
COUNTRIES IN THAT ABBEY AND ALSO
THE REGULAR PEOPLE WHOM SHE HAD
HONORED.
>> AND I WAS THINKING ABOUT
THIS, AS WELL.
THE COFFIN THERE WITH THE ROYAL
STANDARD WITH THE SEPTRE AND THE
ORB, AND IT WAS VERY MUCH LIKE
THE QUEEN DURING HER LIFETIME
AND PEOPLE JUST HAD TO CATCH A
GLIMPSE OF HER AND IT TOUCHED
THEM AND SOMETHING THEY'LL
REMEMBER FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES AND THE CROWDS OF PEOPLE
OUTLINING THE HIGHWAY TO SEE
JUST A QUEEN GOING PAST.
SHE MEANT SO MUCH TO SO MANY
PEOPLE AND THE FACT THAT YOU
HAVE THE WHOLE WORLD GATHER
THERE TO PAY THEIR RESPECTS SUMS
IT ALL UP.
>> WE WERE SAYING IN THE UK IN A
NORMAL YEAR THERE WERE TWO OR
THREE STATE VISITS AND THERE
WERE HUNDREDS OF STATE VISITS IN
JUST DAYS ALL GATHERED TOGETHER
AND AS YOU WATCH THAT PROCESSION
IN THE ABBEY.
WHAT WAS THE EMOTION LIKE WHEN
YOU SAW KING CHARLES ALL OF THE
WAY DOWN TO PRINCE GEORGE, THE
9-YEAR-OLD SON OF KATE AND
WILLIAM.
DID YOU SEE THE EMOTIONS ON
THEIR FACES?
>> I THINK THEIR COMPOSURE WAS
REMARKABLE.
I THINK THE CHILDREN
PARTICULARLY ARE EXTREMELY WELL
BEHAVED.
I THOUGHT THAT IT WAS A VERY
DIFFICULT MOMENT FOR THEM
PARTICULARLY AS THEY WERE
WALKING IN PROCESSION BEHIND THE
COFFIN.
IT MUST HAVE TAKEN GREAT COURAGE
TO DO THAT.
WE'VE SEEN THEM ON DISPLAY OVER
THE COURSE OF THE LAST TEN DAYS,
AND THEY HAVE MANAGED TO CONTAIN
THEIR EMOTIONS EXCEPTIONALLY
WELL, BUT NEVERTHELESS, IT
APPEARS TO HAVE BEEN VERY
DIFFICULT.
I THOUGHT THE KING -- AT "GOD
SAVE THE KING" IN THE ABBEY AND
IT WAS A HUGE MOMENT FOR HIM.
>> HOW WAS HIS FACE?
COULD YOU SEE HIS INTERNAL,
EMOTIONS AS THEY PLAYED THAT?
>> HE LOOKED VERY SOLEMN.
MY GOODNESS, HE HAS SAT IN THAT
PLACE SO MANY YEARS AND THAT
SAVED "GOD SAVE THE QUEEN" AND
THAT WAS A HUGE MOMENT IN HIS
LIFE.
>> IT'S A MOMENT, RICHARD, WHEN
HE REALIZED -- THERE'S THE
EXHAUSTION AND THE PROCESS AND
THEY'VE KNOWN THIS WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN AND THERE ARE STILL
MOMENTS AS A HUMAN BEING.
>> AND THAT IS WHAT MANY OF US
ARE STILL COMING TO TERMS WITH
AS BRITISH CITIZENS THAT THAT
MOMENT WE KNEW IT COULDN'T LAST
FOREVER, BUT NOW OH, IT'S
HAPPENED AND TO YOUR POINT ABOUT
THE KING.
HE SUMMED IT UP, THE WEIGHT OF
HISTORY.
IT'S WORTH REMEMBERING, IT'S
OBVIOUS, I KNOW, BUT IT'S WORTH
REMEMBERING THAT THESE PEOPLE,
15, 20 DEEP WATCHING THIS
PROCESSION.
THEY'RE THERE VOLUNTARILY.
THEY'RE THERE BECAUSE THEY MADE
AN INDIVIDUAL DECISION.
SOME COUNTRIES WHERE YOU BUS
THEM IN, WAS THERE NO NEED TO
HERE.
BY THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
PEOPLE ARE ON THE BY THEIR
CHOICE.
>> RICHARD, YOU SAID SOMETHING A
FEW MOMENTS AGO AND WE WERE
AREN'T ON AIR AND YOU SAID THAT
HAD YOU NOT BEEN WORKING YOU
WOULD HAVE BEEN THERE.
>> IT'S NOT AN IF OR POSSIBILITY
AND IT'S A WHEN.
IF I'D NOT BEEN WORKING THIS
WEEK, I WOULD HAVE SLEPT ON THE
STREETS AS I DID FOR THE WEDDING
OF CHARLES AND DIANA AND DIANA'S
FUNERAL AS I'VE BEEN WORKING THE
ROYAL EVENTS AND NO QUESTION
ABOUT IT.
FOR ME IT WOULD HAVE BEEN THE
ONLY PLACE TO BE.
>> THE ONLY PLACE TO BE, THE
BELOVED FIGURE.
AS YOU THINK BACK ON YOUR
MEMORIES, YOU'VE MET THE QUEEN.
>> THIS IS PART OF HISTORY AND
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE HAVE COME
TOGETHER IN THIS MOMENT OF
COMMUNITY, IN UNITY AND FOR A
FEW DAYS TO RISE ABOVE THE FRAY
AND TO HAVE THIS AMAZING
OUTPOURING.
THEY'RE TRAVELING WEST OF LONDON
NOW ON A ROAD THAT WOULD
NORMALLY TAKE TO THE AIRPORT AND
GO TO WINDSOR TO SITUATE WHERE
THE MOTORCADE IS.
ONE THING WE LEARNED, ERIN, THE
PIPER AT THE END OF THE FUNERAL
IN THE ABBEY WAS THE SAME PIPER
WHO WOKE HER UP EVERY MORNING AT
7:15 PLAYING THE PIPES UNDER HER
WINDOW FOR 15 MINUTES AND THAT'S
THE REMARKABLE THING AND AS KATE
WILLIAMS ALLUDED TO, THIS QUEEN
ONCED TO HER PEOPLE AND HER
TROOPS I AM NOT THE KIND OF
MONARCH WHO CAN DIRECT YOU INTO
WAR OR PASS LEGISLATION, BUT
WHAT I CAN GIVE YOU IS MY LOVE
AND MY SERVICE, AND YOU KNOW,
SHE'S GOING TO BE BURIED IN ST.
GEORGE'S CHAPEL WHERE WE'VE JUST
HEARD HENRY VIII IS MARRIED AND
HIS DAUGHTER WAS THE ELIZ
ELIZABETHAN, SENDING HER TROOPS
IN BATTLE, I HAVE THE BODY OF A
WEAK AND FEEBLE WOMAN AND I HAVE
THE HEART OF OF A KING AND THE
KING OF ENGLAND, AT THAT AND
IT'S REMARKABLE THAT THIS SECOND
ELIZABETH WAS ABLE IN SOME WAY
TO ALSO HAVE THAT POWER JUST BY
THE MAJESTY AND THE UNITY THAT
SHE BROUGHT EVEN THOUGH IT'S NOT
GOVERNING POWER.
>> AND CHRISTIANE, YOU ALSO, I
MENTIONED BRIEFLY, BUT TELL US
ABOUT MEETING THE QUEEN.
>> WELL, LOOK, I MEAN, YOU KNOW,
I WAS VERY, VERY PROUD TO HAVE
BEEN HONORED BY THE QUEEN.
THE GOVERNMENT DRAWS UP A LIST
FOR WHO ARE GOING TO GET WHAT'S
CALLED QUEEN'S HONORS, AND I GOT
MINE FOR SERVICES TO JOURNALISM,
AND IT REMAINS, YOU KNOW, A
SOURCE OF GREAT PRIDE.
AND SHE WAS WONDERFUL, AND I
THANKED HER AT THE TIME FOR
THAT, BUT ALSO FOR OPENING THE
CNN OFFICE HERE IN LONDON.
SO HERE'S THE THING, JUST TO SAY
THAT JUST ABOUT EVERYBODY AS
EMILY HAS SAID AND OTHERS HAVE
SAID, HAVE A MOMENT WHETHER IT'S
US, WHETHER IT'S THE ROYAL
FAMILY AND DIGNITARIES, ALL OF
THE PEOPLE WHO MET HER ON HER
WALK ABOUT ON HER OPENINGS OF
ROADS --
>> WAIT, SHE WAS --?
SCHOOLS.
>> SHE WAS TOUCHABLE TO THE
AVERAGE PERSON.
>> AND PEOPLE FEEL THAT THEY
KNEW HER AND THEY KIND OF DID
BECAUSE IT WAS 70 YEARS
ESPECIALLY THE CHRISTMAS
BROADCAST.
THAT WAS A TANGIBLE THING.
>> EVEN IN THE U.S. WE SAW THAT
EVERY YEAR.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
TALKED ABOUT WAS THE ABILITY OF
HER TO BE ORDINARY WITH YOU, AND
WHEN I MET HER, WHEN SHE OPENED
THE CNN OFFICE IN LONDON, WE
WERE TERRIBLY WORRIED.
WOULD SHE TAKE THE STAIRS OR THE
RAMP?
>> THERE SHE IS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WHAT SHE'S TALKING ABOUT THERE,
SHE'S ASKING ME WHAT ABOUT MY
EARPIECE?
>> REALLY?
?
YES.
SHE WAS FASCINATED THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO TALK AND LISTEN AT THE
SAME TIME, AND SHE WAS QUITE --
SHE HAD THAT -- I'VE HEARD IT A
MILLION TIMES.
SHE HAD THAT ABILITY TO MAKE YOU
FEEL YOU WERE JUST THE PERSON
SHE WAS HOPING TO MEET.
>> WELL, THAT'S A GIFT.
SO FEW HUMAN BEINGS HAVE.
>> THE OTHER TIME I SAW HER, I
SAW HER HAND AND I WAS COVERING
MIKHAIL GORBACHEV'S VISIT TO THE
CASTLE AND I WAS A YOUNG
REPORTER AND I STAYED LATER THAN
I SHOULD HAVE DONE BECAUSE IN
THE LIVE REPORT AND I WAS
DOWNSTAIRS AND THEN I SUDDENLY
REALIZED IN FRONT OF ME THERE
WAS A FORTMAN, A BUTLER HOLDING
A GLASS AND OUT CAME A HAND AND
YOU COULD HEAR THE QUEEN SAY
"THANK YOU" AND I BACKED OFF
BEFORE I GOT ARRESTED.